idea it feels a little bit as though uh
covert data has slipped off the agenda
but we keep tracking rises of the last
few weeks yes it's exactly what i was
just about to say it does feel a bit
like we're seeing these rises the the
thing to note is that everything seems
to be rising so the trend is going
upward so that is
the number of covered cases
is rising but also
it seems to be rising across the nations
i'll go through these figures with you
now covered cases have risen to 1.74
million across the country in the week
until the 18th of june that compares to
1.42 million cases in the week to the
11th of june and what that means is that
the number is higher overall but it's a
lower figure by which it is rising now
if you go through the different nations
what it shows is that one in 45 people
in wales had covid in the week ending
the 18th of june
for england that number is one in 40.
for northern ireland it's one in 30 and
for scotland that figure is one in 20.
now what is causing
these rises well the ons that's the
office for national statistics says that
it is
likely to be caused by infections
compatible with omicron's ba 0.4 and ba
point
5 variants now they're not the dominant
strains at the ba 0.2 still up until
june
june 12th was
accountable for about three quarters of
the country's cases but we know that
that that one ba 0.2 the one that is
responsible for three quarters is 50
more transmissible but according to a
study in boston the ba 0.4 and the ba
0.5 are three times as resistant to
neutralizing antibodies as the 0.1 and
0.2 so a little bit complicated there
but if we look at it in terms of
practical things we know that when it's
summer people are mixing more perhaps
people are traveling more um
so covered cases can go up with hay
fever people sneeze more that can we
know spread covered more easily what
we're not seeing is hospitals under
pressure and so we don't know what the
exact figures are for
hospital admissions a lot of people that
are admitted to hospital may
incidentally have covid but may be
admitted
for reasons other than
for covid
the good news if we can say is that
people appear to continue to be testing
um whether that's because they're
testing through habits or because they
know they're going to be in close
contact with someone who's vulnerable
or even because they need a negative
test in order to travel so the good sign
is that there is still a lot of testing
going on in the community